my members have great confidence in the
NHS continuing but it needs some TLC
some serious TLC and we're very pleased
to see the investment in Staffing but if
you talk to both the public and we've
we've surveyed the public and my members
they will say that we need two more
things to happen first we need
investment in Social care because that
is a real Block in moving people out of
hospital and getting them in looking
after them when they've left so they
don't go back in and we also need
investment in capital
um because there are too many hospitals
and too many mental health trusts and
too many GP surgeries and too many other
Capital intensive services that need
money and all that is is actually
affecting the efficiency and
effectiveness of the NHS so at the
moment we've got one leg of the stool
um very very grateful for the funding
for Staffing but there's two of the legs
that need to be shored up and invested
in yeah and you moved me on to the
social care piece a little sooner than I
wanted to but I'm going to stick with
the NHS that's all right I saw your
tweet this morning and I know that that
is a key element that you guys want to
talk about but you mentioned the
workforce plan that came last week that
offers funding for five years I mean
that's not good enough is it
well it's a start I mean right now we
went into the pandemic with a hundred
thousand nearest family hundred thousand
vacancies we've now got over 120 000
um it's not sustainable we've been
calling for a fully funded Workforce
plan for some time I think NHS England
have done a really good job in actually
putting the workforce plan together and
we we very we're grateful we you know at
least the government's funding that it's
a long-term plan it will require
um uh successive governments to invest
and it will be also require a lot of
hard work between my colleagues and the
confed NHS England in order to make it
happen but you know we're grateful we're
just very clear that it's not enough in
and of itself no it's not enough and
look you both of your answers you have
mentioned the funding piece I don't know
if you saw the uh uh debate between Lord
Winston and Dr Gerardo earlier there is
a difference of opinion as to how the
NHS should be funded long term where do
you fall on what um what form of funding
the NHS we're very we're very clear and
I think the public are very clear in our
in our surveys of them they want the
they want the NHS to be free at the
point of need and they want the the NHS
to be funded through taxation and at the
end of the day you know it's the NHS
isn't free we all pay for it through our
tax and it's the best insurance you can
have actually because you've got 60
million people back in you and other
systems tend to lead to discrepancies
and serious problems with people who are
poor poorer or are sicker and actually
we have a very efficient system and we
and we need to continue to commit to it
it's worth pointing out that for every
one pound we spend on the NHS we add
four pounds to the British economy so
this is this is about investment and we
need to think of it like that there is
no wealth without health no absolutely
not but can it be augmented is my point
uh Lord uh can we add to it you know
everyone wants it to remain free at the
point of need but it needs extra money
and those who pass can pay more should
they it does it does need to be invested
in I think there's a real question about
that we we're already seeing people who
can't afford Private health care
struggle um to get health care because
they don't want to be left on a 7.42
million uh waiting list I think it gets
very complicated when you start talking
about additional funds I mean there are
people who will choose to go private but
that's not the NHS that the people know
and love and we should continue to
providing free at the point of access
and free at the point of need I'm
running short time I just want to get
your thoughts on social care do you
think this government takes the social
care reform needed
seriously
what we would hope they do and we've
been certainly asking for uh proper
funding for social care it doesn't make
sense actually to to provide the funding
for Staffing and then not provide social
care actually 120 000 vacancies in the
NHS you've got 160
000 vacancies in Social care we need a
plan for social care too we've written
to the to number 10 under Health
Minister seeking that assurance that
that will come it is deeply concerning
that we haven't had the conversations
that we need to have around social care
it is the missing piece and most people
and the public are starting to
understand yeah but without social care
properly funded we don't have a proper
functioning Health and Social care
system